now you may remember our next title from
the end of last year's show when it blew
your [ __ ] mind
and if you're at home playing a drinking
game yes and f-bomb in the first five
minutes of this show ladies and
gentlemen welcome back to Ghost Recon
wildlands
I offer the people a choice to follow me
or oppose me
if you follow me I feed your families
give you shelter medicine and jobs
shield you from the tyrants
allow us and I wanted to protect you
from death
I give you power
I make you rich but most of all I let
you rule like kings but for those that
oppose me
I have only one thing to offer
a promise
to take everything you love
and destroy it in front of your eyes
it's all yours
get the money the drugs the cake
in Bolivia the coca leaf is core to the
culture it's found in every gas station
every hospital and every town square and
they use it for a variety of things like
treating nausea and altitude sickness to
a refreshing energy drink but it can
also be used to make cocaine so we asked
what if what if a Mexican drug cartel
moved in took over the entire country
seized all of those cocoa resources to
become the number one producer of
cocaine on the planet effectively
turning Bolivia into a narco-state this
is the world of Ghost Recon wildlands
and you well you're the ghosts the elite
spec ops drop deep behind enemy lines to
create chaos and disrupt the alliance
between a corrupt local government and
the Santa Blanca cartel ultimately going
after their leader the vicious El sueño
hi everybody my name is Dominick Butler
I'm the lead game designer for Ghost
Recon wildlands
a Ghost Recon wildlands is the very
first military shooter said in a massive
dangerous open world that you can play
entirely in solo or in up to four player
co-op with beautiful environments set
across a variety of different ecosystems
that will challenge and influence your
gameplay at every step of the way all of
this takes place in the largest
action-adventure open-world Ubisoft has
ever done now in the gameplay we're
about to show you the ghosts already
have a target his name is el pozolero
he's known as the stewmaker because he
makes the bodies disappear the ghosts
know that their target is in a large
Santa Blanca camp somewhere in the san
mateo province but they don't know where
yet exactly and because Ghost Recon
wildlands gives you the total freedom of
choice to do what you want when you want
we put the power back in the player's
hands to achieve their objectives their
way in this case the ghosts know that
their target has some vital Intel they
want to take him alive so they've opted
for a tactical extraction let's go get
that Intel
there we go the Intel we need supposed
to be in this sicarios house looks like
it's upstairs
copy that need any help no I got this
okay I'll take a look around right let's
try to keep it stealthy there's one
right there I'm in oh [ __ ] up it's fine
good yep got it just move upstairs all
right let's see what we got okay I got
the intel on el pozolero he's in a camp
up in San Mateo go how far is it we
could use a ride you got a car out there
now something better
you ready to fly
let's go you got it
according to the Intel the camp should
be near this clip l puzzler was a
high-value target he's gonna be well
protected there's a camp oh damn this
was gonna be tough yeah we could
definitely use some backup on this one
hey you guys need a hand right on time
we're going after el pozolero we're at
the east of the San Mateo base got it we
are on our way we're approaching the
camp from the West we'll meet you there
copy that
they hear this pozolero guy supposed to
be a hard target how bad does it look
see for yourself well damn looks like a
whole lot of trouble tag to look out can
you get him Roger that one less to worry
about
okay we're splitting up Weaver can you
get to a good sniper position on the
south side of the camp no problem
alrighty I'm moving in from the other
side copy that we're moving in from the
train station at the east end of camp
it's up enemy spotted I got eyes on a
sniper wait for my signal got it now
tango Down let's move
okay wait a minute I hear something
inside - guys I got the one on the right
you ready ready good god good job
okay I'm gonna deploy the drone and see
what's up ahead
looks like an old town that's not the
Blancas turned into a base oh man there
are guards all over the place that bad
yep be careful one down so far so good
not my waiting guys all right let's see
what's in this big building okay I got
him red gloves gas masks
he's got guards with him got it and
another one down I'm moving through
gotcha okay and close to the building I
try to find a way in you saw anything
else and I think he was dissolving
somebody like in a can of acid or
something yeah look pretty nasty come on
guys let's move all right all right I
think I found my spot nearly there
carrot fall is more than close to you
gasps only one left
okay I'm in position I have three tangos
in front of me we everything you can
help I got it going in don't let this
guy get away see him we'll talk about a
nightmare fuel call us if you need it
don't worry man I got this [ __ ] spotted
me guys spotted that puzzlers running
going after him where is he where is he
he's in a white SUV heading for the East
End of the camp all got a bike
got it I'm moving to intercept this
camps on full alert guys we need to get
out of here fast
Oh get the car where's the prisoner easy
[ __ ] no he's moving too fast with the
other way
come on man let's go let's go hurry up
the gates closed I'm right behind you
Weaver are you okay
I'm good
found a bike guys I'm on my way
they watch your fire we need him alive I
can't get a good shot this guy's all
over the place
stop moving okay guys I'm clear down to
the camp on the road where are you guys
let me know your Dan the whole place is
going up
alright I'm headed for the chopper now
damn he's trying to ram the car I gotta
hit his engine now I try slowing down
I was on the way guys over on this train
where's the chopper where's I found it
okay getting in I'm in the chopper
coming your way
alright I'm on my way guys hang tight oh
no no no he's not stopping
man come on come on I'm trying he's a
tough one this guy huh he's losing
control can you push them to this side I
don't know how it looks up there but
that's what I'm trying to do
yeah they dodged it hang on guys I'm
nearly there
I'll get careful rise here how'd you get
buddy
hurry up we got cartel reinforcements
incoming hope you get in you go adios
let's get the hell out of here
thank god I'm in my line fire we'll hold
them off I gotta fly this thing
and we are clear gentlemen nice we're
now the top mission command that was
close
head over to Ghost Recon comm right now
for all the latest news and gameplay
videos for those of you here at e3
please come by the booth we've got four
player co-op demos and we would love for
you to try it we want to get your
feedback Ghost Recon wildlands will be
released on March 7th 2017 thank you
have a great show